I want some of this mmm Vienna sausage
so tasty
by 2050 reports predict that there will
be more plastic in the ocean than fish
how does this plastic even get in the
ocean in the first place well a lot of
it is from the trash in our streets that
go into our storm drains and then get
washed out into our oceans so today I'm
going to be trying to pick up all the
trash in my neighborhood I live in
beautiful little Armenia Los Angeles
which is a relatively small neighborhood
in East Hollywood I have no idea how
much trash there will actually be but
I'm gonna try to pick up as much as I
can okay already I see some trash this
isn't my apartment complex - so there
was street cleaning on the side of the
street today
I know plastic is so scary I think I
might fill these bags was just some one
block which is crazy I don't think I'm
gonna be a little neighborhood I'm gonna
try we'll see how far I get this I can
recycle put in my recycling one follow
these little pieces of plastic they take
like 400 plus years to break down all
the plastic that has ever been created
still exists in our world so the idea of
like throwing something away there's
really no way anyone wants them note
your cheese hey this streets a little
cleaner I mean if you look closely
there's definitely still pieces of trash
I'm just focusing on the big pieces
because there's so many little pieces
I'm not bothering to pick up the
cigarette butts it's too much so much
ring
it is really crazy how many went on this
isn't Starbucks try something I don't
know what this is this is trash I'm
gonna put these clothes in and maybe we
could take them to the goodwill
floor definitely getting across the
point that there's a lot of trash in my
neighborhood the whole furniture is
trash but I can't get all of it okay so
I got so much trash and clothes that I
asked AMRO to come and help me load some
of it in so I can keep on picking up
trash thank you this is how straws and
other plastics get into the ocean they
go into these drains and then they get
washed out to sea
premium vodka can recycle this some
chicken bones delicious this is
definitely not a one-person job but I
just wanted to see what it would be like
and see how much trash actually is there
because like I notice it but then I
haven't actually spent time trying to
pick it up it's pretty clean over here
it is crazy though just like the
difference in neighborhood and how one
neighborhood in LA has trashed and the
other ones don't
trash in the trees a little surprise
okay we're back on my streets just gonna
do the other side oh okay
so we made it back to my apartment this
is actually a crazy amount of trash I
definitely didn't pick up all the trash
in my neighborhood in fact I probably
only covered like 20 percent but for
three hours I think this is a crazy
amount of waste these three bags are all
textile waste which I'm gonna donate to
Goodwill
this is recycling which I'm gonna
recycle and this is all just trash the
most common items that I saw on the
street besides textile waste were Flyers
cigarette packages and fast food
packaging I'm gonna throw it away if
you're bummed about seeing trash in our
streets and wondering what you can do
about it you can start by trying to cut
out single-use plastics like straws
to-go cups and water bottles good luck
I'm in love with this grabber now gonna
be a lifelong relationship Hey unsub is
on a new channel and know your part
subscribe here that was my part